la violence à l'école et après le jeu du
foulard on parle maintenant de celui de
la can est un collégien de 13 ans a été
hospitalisé pendant trois jours près de
nice après avoir été lynché par ses
camarades dans les cours de récréation
des établissements scolaires ces jeux
sont loin d'être des exceptions la
plupart des adolescents en sont témoins
jennifer alberte vous aviez un moment
une quinzaine une quinzaine à se jeter
sur lui parce qu'il n'avait pas
rattraper la canette de soda conduit
lancé il y a une semaine un élève de 5e
de ce collège du var c'est proprement
fait passer à tabac au moment de la
récré ils avaient perdu au jeu de la can
est un jeu célèbre dans les
établissements scolaires et dont les
règles n'ont rien de pacifique et à une
personne qui a aplati on canettes et je
refuse tout un pays où il atteint 15
personnes qui passent et le tchèque jan
à quelqu'un qui jette la canette de tuer
tout le monde arrive dessus et le fera
qu'il est loin le temps où les cours de
récréation raisonnée du simple bruit des
balles ont fini la balle au prisonnier
autres matchs de foot aujourd'hui place
à la pièce qui tourne ou aux paumes de
mains des jeux au nom plutôt gentillet
mais qui finissent toujours par faire
mal et des amusements de ce genre il y
en a pléthore dans les collèges et les
lycées
qui vont avec un ballon il faut passer
faire passer le ballon à la légère entre
les jambes après tout le monde a le
droit de le taper le taper pourquoi bois
parce qu'il a perdu ses papiers a perdu
ya du jeu de la pièce alors on pose une
pièce de reprendre la main la lance en
l'air et cantons sur le
le plat de la main on doit la bloquer
entre eux entre les différents doigt
quand ça se bloquent entre ses deux
doigts là on est rappeur français
bloquent entre les autres doigts on est
juge si ça tombe par terre on est frappé
et le juge décide du nombre de coups et
puis après le rapport
les jeunes reconnaissent la violence de
leur jeu mais selon eux faire mal n'est
pas ce qui les attire même si cela
pimente un peu les règles parfois il ya
dérapage comme la semaine dernière dans
le var le collégien battu par ses
camarades s'en tire avec plusieurs
hématomes dont un sérieux au foie il
n'ira pas à l'école pendant dix jours et
ses parents ont porté plainte contre x
pour coups et blessures volontaires
quentin a été victime du jeu de la
canette résultat un séjour à l'hôpital
et dix jours d'arrêt il s'est fait
tabasser sous le préau du collège par
une dizaine d'élèves parce qu'il a raté
la canette qui lui était élancé j'ai
plus trop envie d'y retourner au collège
parce que ça se passe un plein jour ça
peut se passer avec des couteaux des
trucs comme j'ai trop envie d'y
retourner en collège quentin ne
retournera pas au collège coubertin sa
mère a porté plainte pour elle cette
agression n'est pas excusable
d'emménager les parents et parents d
élèves je pense aussi qu'il devrait vous
une certaine petite discussion avec
leurs enfants on leur apprend la non
violence que ce soit à l'école ou à la
maison aussi orsyp en baisse les bras
avec des gamins de 13 ans qu'est ce
qu'ils vont devenir les prochains tuer
tout le monde le principal de
l'établissement qui peut être jugés
pénalement responsable de ce qui s'est
passé déplore bien sûr l'accident il
avait fait mettre des panneaux pour
interdire le jeu de l'as cannes est
pratique et déjà l'an dernier biache et
or peut dire que voir un lieu n'est
jamais suffisamment surveillé mais
est-ce qu'il faut toujours trop
surveillé faut-il placer une personne
derrière chaque enfin pour les
associations de parents et les syndicats
d'enseignants le collage fait ce qu'il
peut le manque de moyens pour surveiller
la demi pension est à imputer à
l'académie et entend parents des amis
nous tenons avant tout à défendre notre
collège et c'est vrai que nous par
contre nous nous tenons vraiment à
ah je dire associé cet incident au fait
qu' il manque du personnel dans ce
collège au niveau des élèves on essaie
de les responsabiliser de faire prendre
conscience des problèmes que peuvent
engendrer d'état la paix tel jeu la
gendarmerie a saisi du dossier pour bien
sûr retrouver les auteurs des coups mais
aussi déterminer les responsabilités de
cette violence non maîtrisée
[Musique]